[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
ce mardi 14 janvier 50 start-up présente
aujourd'hui sur le site d'airbus à
elancourt elles ont été sélectionnées
par le groupe dans le but de nouer des
partenariats au terme de cette journée
des collaborations pour mener des
projets d'innovation dans la
cybersécurité la défense et l
aéronautique est les travaux ont débuté
l'été dernier à montigny le bretonneux
le forum des arts charles aznavour sort
peu à peu de terre en lieu et place de
l'ancien collège bergson un projet dédié
à la culture accompagné de la
construction de 140 logements
et puis c'est une référence dans
l'univers de la danse thierry malandain
proposait deux de ses créations le
week-end dernier au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un territoire
qu'il connaît bien lui qui avait fondé
sa compagnie en 1986 à elancourt cet
incident d'abord à huy qui a fait fort
heureusement plus de peur que de mal
un immeuble a été soufflée par une
explosion survenue la nuit dernière vers
minuit rue henri barbusse une toiture et
des murs entièrement détruit aucune
victime n'est cependant à déplorer le
commerce est le seul appartement qui
occupent les lieux étaient vides au
moment des faits pas d'hypothèse sur
l'origine de l'explosion avancée pour le
moment les yvelines plus peuplés qu'en
2012 le département a gagné en cinq ans
vingt-six mille habitants soit une
augmentation de 1 8% statistiques
établies par l'insee entre 2012 et 2017
qui fixe la population yvelinoise à plus
d'un million quatre cent trente mille
personnes augmentation en lien avec les
chiffres francilien est due selon
l'institut un fort excédent des
naissances sur les décès si on prend
l'exemple de saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération compte et en 2017
deux mille habitants de plus qu'en 2012
[Musique]
le site d'airbus à elancourt a accueilli
aujourd'hui près de 50 start-up toute la
journée et les collaborateurs du groupe
ont pu rencontrer les dirigeants de ces
sociétés innovantes l'objectif conclure
et des partenariats et développer des
projets d'innovation le reportage de
nicolas landry et de jacques brun c'est
le futur avion de combat européen tout
un système connecté avec notamment
plusieurs drones pour la start-up jcp
connect basée à rennes ce projet est une
opportunité pour créer une collaboration
avec airbus
cette société de 12 salariés est
spécialisée dans la conception de
logiciels destinés aux drones on
s'occupe de ce type de communication le
réseau de drones à deux objectifs
c'est effectivement de transmettre les
données venons capteurs qui peuvent être
des captures vidéos ou d'autres types de
capteurs avec une fiabilité qui est
bonne c'est également d'assurer la
sécurité parce que effectivement ce type
de réseau peut être vulnérable à deux
types d' attaque d'une part une attaque
venant d'un capteur onf au capteur ou
une attaque venant dans drôles comme jcp
connect ils sont une cinquantaine de
start up à présenter leurs activités aux
collaborateurs d'airbus cybersécurité
intelligence artificielle spatiale
plusieurs secteurs d'innovation ouvert à
des partenariats par le groupe
aéronautique avec linster en fait si une
start up qui a développé une imprimante
3d qui nous intéresse beaucoup
parce qu'elle est capable d'utiliser un
certain nombre de matériaux basée à
bayonne linster a été créé en 2015 elle
propose des imprimantes 3d destinés à la
production ou à la conception de
prototypes
cette pièce est là était allé à dire en
étude pour il représente une application
de protection de câbles électriques pour
un avion
et il ya des spécificités matière à
respecter pour que la pièce puisse
résister à des hydrocarbures des huiles
moteurs 1 du kérosène déjà partenaire
d'airbus à toulouse elle souhaite
développer une collaboration avec
l'activité defence and space sur un
sujet confidentiel dans l'actualité
également cet ultimatum brandie par
environ 1200 médecins un responsable de
service dont cinq du centre hospitalier
françois quesnay de mantes-la-jolie et 4
de l'hôpital mignot situe aux chaînés
rocancourt dans une tribune publiée dans
le journal libération aujourd'hui ils
menacent de démissionner de leurs
fonctions administratives une décision
avancé depuis décembre pour dénoncer le
manque de moyens et de personnel dans
les hôpitaux publics
le plan d'urgence annoncé par agnès
buzyn en novembre ne les a pas rassurés
ils somment la ministre de la santé et
d'ouvrir des négociations pour réformer
l'hôpital sans quoi ils démissionneront
un contexte de grève auquel s'ajoute
cette mobilisation actuelle 1 contre la
réforme des retraites le mouvement qui
est rentrée ce mardi dans son 41ème jour
et les conditions de circulation dans
les transports se sont cependant
nettement améliorée depuis lundi après
l'annoncé du gouvernement du retrait
provisoire de l'âge pivot amélioration
qui devrait se poursuivre demain
mercredi vos conditions de circulation à
retrouver sur les sites de la ratp et de
transilien
c'est en cette période de galère dans
les transports que le collectif vélos
ile de france a choisi de dévoiler la
carte de son projet le rer v réseau
express régional vélo autrement dit
relier l'ensemble de l'île de france
grâce à un réseau de pistes cyclables
cohérent et surtout interconnecté vous
le voyez neuf lignes en tout qui
pourrait permettre de se rendre
facilement à versailles vélizy ou encore
saint nom la bretèche et depuis un an 33
associations travaillent sur ce projet
qui nécessite forcément un fort
investissement écouter
parti se partager un constat entre
associations en ile de france il est
très compliqué de se déplacer à vélo
d'une ville à une autre alors qu'en
voiture vous avez des lignes vous avez
des routes départementales en herbe vous
avez des lignes aussi vous avez des
voies ferrées alors qu'en vélo vous avez
des petits bouts par ci par là un des
bouts de pistes et nous voulons coller
les morceaux ensemble pour en fait des
véritables lignes et même un réseau
qu'on appellera donc le rer vélo le rer
b
afin de permettre à tous les franciliens
de se déplacer plus facilement le
collectif qui chiffre à 500 millions
d'euros ce projet de rer vélo impact de
la transition en vue de
des élections municipales et pour
contrer l'urgence climatique pour faire
face à l'urgence climatique c'est
l'initiative prise par une soixantaine
d'organisations au niveau national une
opération décliné dans les yvelines par
18 associations elles proposent ce pacte
aux élections municipales dans les 36
communes de l'agglomération rambouillet
territoire un texte avec quatorze
mesures en faveur de la transition
écologique et solidaire
objectif sensibiliser les futures
équipes municipales sur les questions
environnementales les propos sont
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude tous les candidats qui le
veulent qu'ils sont intéressés nous nous
demande de signer le pacte tout qu'on
leur présente on leur présente le pacte
il est à prendre
intégralité dans l'intégralité tel qu'il
est là tout ou rien et quand ils le
signe ils s'engagent eux à mettre en
oeuvre toutes ces actions là sur la
durée du mandat et nous on s'engage avec
toutes les expertises qu'on a beaucoup
d'expertisé sur le territoire à donner
de l' expertise du temps de l'énergie
pour mettre en oeuvre ces actions là les
scientifiques sont unanimes pour dire
que tous les signaux sont au rouge
ils sont aussi unanimes pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui 60% des leviers sont
délais dans les mains des politiques
territoriales et locales
donc maintenant il faut vraiment que les
mairies qui vont avoir les candidats et
notamment les mères qui vont être élus
pour avoir des responsabilités très
lourdes sur la décennie qui arrive en
termes sur le terme d'écologie et la
solidarité une réunion de présentation
est programmée à rambouillet le 28
janvier au théâtre du nickel en présence
de yann arthus yann arthus bertrand et
pour suivre l'actualité des élections
municipales ne manquez pas ce soir un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 politique
présentée par wilfrid richy ma première
invitée dans ce journal lucie robin
bonsoir ça et directrice du cidff des
yvelines le centre d'information sur le
droit des femmes et des familles et
directrice et même bientôt ex directrice
car vous allez passer la main à la fin
du mois après 14 ans passés dans les
yvelines à ce poste est ce qu'il y à un
impasse un pincement au coeur quand vous
pensez à ce départ oui bien sûr
s'appelle cidf si facilement vous avez
passé 14 ans à la direction du cidff des
yvelines qu'est ce qui a pu être
accompli alors dans les grandes lignes
de quoi êtes vous le plus fier quand
vous regardez ce bilan alors en fait je
n'ai pas fait de 14 ans
de direction j'ai d'abord été juriste
pendant près de six ans avant de
reprendre la direction pendant huit ans
est alors sur le parcours
évidemment l'accompagnement des
personnes ça a été très riche il ya des
situations qui ont pu être très
marquante dans cet accompagnement
particulier auprès des victimes des
femmes victimes de violences et après
sur le poste de direction oui des
actions marquantes si on a eu beaucoup
on a réalisé des spots de promotion de
l'égalité professionnelle par exemple
avec un groupe de femmes éloignées de
l'emploi
d'ailleurs vous aviez invité pour en
parler ça a été quelque chose de très
riches on avait participé à un concours
aussi autour de l'accompagnement
professionnel des femmes éloignées de
l'emploi qu'on avait remporté en 2012
c'était c'est aussi quelque chose de
marquant pour l'association
et puis plus récemment les 35 ans du
cidf aussi qui avait été fêté à
guyancourt où on avait pu en faire un
événement festif avec déclic théâtre
notamment avec les hôtesses donc ça
c'est aussi quelque chose de marquant
et puis toutes les actions du quotidien
le cidf l'accompagnement emploi
l'accompagnement juridique l'aide aux
victimes tout ça oui c'est quelque chose
de marquant et qui continuera à
m'accompagner les valeurs du cidf
continue tout au long de la suite avec
forcément des derniers mois marqués par
le grenelle des violences conjugales le
cidff a été grandement impliqué dans
l'affairé oui on a participé au grenelle
et plusieurs groupes de travail sur
lesquelles cidf était évidemment présent
et avec des chutes effectivement positif
pour ce grenelle le travail notamment
sur un réseau des réseaux un projet de
bons taxi pour les femmes victimes pour
se déplacer sur le département qui est
grand pour aller à l'unité médico
judiciaire de versailles quand on habite
à mantes ça peut être compliqué
également sur le dispositif vite et les
fans d' alerte pour les femmes en grave
danger une augmentation de ce nombre de
téléphones qui était limité sur le
département
donc oui il en sort beaucoup de choses
positives évident plein de souvenirs
dans la tête vous l'avez dit quelle
évolution vous avez pu constater pendant
ces 14 ans leur fin 2017
il y a eu ce mouvement ni tout un moment
mondiale suite aux révélations de la fer
wang xin
est ce que depuis la parole des femmes
est ce que vous avez constaté qu'elle
s'est davantage libéré cette parole des
femmes oui tout à fait et nous on a
constaté vraiment une augmentation du
nombre de signalements des violences que
ce soit des victimes elles mêmes mais
aussi la plus récemment c'est vraiment
l'effet grenelle des signalements qui
émane de proches donc un père une mère
qui vient signaler que il pense que sa
fille est victime de violence des
voisins aussi parfois ou des amis et ça
on en voyait beaucoup moins avant là
c'est vrai qu'on a vu le nombre de mails
notamment adressé à l'association pour
signaler explosé donc on a une
augmentation de notre activité sur le
volet des violences cette relation
rappelle justement votre activité le
cidff du rappel c'est le centre
d'information sur le droit des femmes
droits des femmes et des familles parmi
ses missions la lutte contre les
violences qu'est ce que vous proposez
en ce sens pour lutter contre les
violences alors nous au quotidien on
propose des permanences juridiques donc
vraiment l'accès aux droits de ces
femmes qui sont victimes de violence
donc les informer sur la procédure aussi
bien civiles que pénales avec des
antennes 50 antennes dans les yvelines
dans des lieux aussi variés que les
points d'accès au droit les maisons de
justice des ccs des maisons de quartier
aussi commissariat également donc ce qui
permet qu'elles puissent aussi choisir
l'endroit où l on est passé on sectorise
pas donc une femme qui habite à montigny
peut très bien les amendes si elle
travaille sûrement tout si ça les
arrange tout simplement d'aller sur
nantes elle fait ce qu'elle veut
on va pas poser de questions il ya 25
ans on propose aussi de l'accompagnement
emploi
avec vraiment un travail sur tous les
freins qui sont liées à ces violences
des groupes de paroles également coanimé
par juristes et psychologues et puis un
soutien psychologique aussi en
individuel qui est possible donc ça
c'est vraiment pour l'accompagnement des
victimes en tant que tel et par rapport
aux professionnels on propose beaucoup
d'actions de formation des
professionnels sur cette thématique là
pour détecter et puis aussi une fois
qu'on a détecté savoir comment orienter
au mieux avec de l'intervention aussi
dans les milieux scolaires se sont mis
alors voilà après une intervention la
prévention des plus jeune âge on a
commencé dès la primaire on pourrait
même envisager la maternelle ça se fait
sur le cidf 92 qui le fait notamment
pour traiter des questions d'égalité
fille-garçon et de la prévention des
violences sexistes donc dès le plus
jeune âge il faut s'y atteler très tôt
très rapidement votre successeur et
leurs carreaux qui prendra son poste au
3 février que lui souhaiter vous mais le
meilleur je lui souhaite autant de
belles actions que celles que j'ai pu
connaître sous ses 14 années mais j'en
doute pas il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire encore au cidff
merci lucie robin bonne continuation à
vous bientôt ex directrice du cidff des
yvelines un poste que vous quitterez à
la fin janvier
c'est l'un merci à vous c'est l'un des
chantiers majeurs de montigny le
bretonneux la construction d'un forum
des arts les travaux ont débuté cet été
première rentrée prévue pour les jeunes
artistes en septembre 2021 retour sur
l'histoire du lieu et visite du chantier
avec marylène yapi chinon il fêté ses 20
ans en septembre 2004 avant d'être ferme
et trois ans plus tard
promesse de campagne de michel logis en
le collège bergson a été détruit en 2017
pour de nouveau accueillir la jeunesse
inhibante haine au sein d'un forum des
arts ce bâtiment va permettre de
regrouper toutes toutes sortes
d'activités qui étaient aujourd'hui
explosé dans des gymnases dans
en des salles communales ou même dans le
petit conservatoire de musique
aujourd'hui était vraiment trop petit
pour le nombre d'élèves accueillant les
premières lettres du forum des arts
charles aznavour apparaissent 3400
mètres carrés qui accueilleront théâtre
musique et danse
les travaux ont débuté en juin dernier
pour une livraison prévue en avril 2021
aujourd'hui ce qui est fait donc c'est
toute la partie sous sol avaient donc le
l'auditorium de 150 places qu'en diront
sur 350 mètres carrés
même la salle de percussions et le
parking de 20 places avec des places 2
pour les vélos et main sur ces places il
y aura des places pour des véhicules et
des véhicules électriques tout le rez de
chaussée et termine également donc on
ressort on revoit l'auditorium qui est
sur deux niveaux qui ressort ici quatre
salles de théâtre et la partie
administrative
un projet confié au maître d'oeuvre
strasbourgeois dominique coulon est
associé spécialiste des bâtiments
culturels aux normes acoustiques
particulière
coût total 18 millions d'euros dont la
majorité est financé par des subventions
et les recettes des logements construits
sur le terrain on voit bien la voix qui
va desservir le bâtiment public et les
quatre îlots de les quatre îlots de
logements bien séparés quatre îlots
comprenant environ 140 logements dont
des logements sociaux pour ce faire
quatre autres grues jammes rond au
printemps à quelques jours de
l'ouverture des inscriptions sur
parcours super aussi pour la saisie des
voeux une grande soirée pour s'orienter
sans stress elle est proposée à la cité
des métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
jeudi soir un afterwork qui est fait
pour les parents afin d'aider leurs
enfants dans leurs projets d'études on
en parle avec anne capitan bonsoir
bonsoir êtes coach en orientation au des
abbés m 78
vous allez animer notamment une soirée
dans lors de cette soirée une conférence
on en parle dans un instant déjà juste
de détailler le des adm 78 qu'est-ce que
je des abbés mais ta face s'intitule le
dispositif académique bilan et mobilité
voilà nous dépendant de l'éducation
nationale dans la branche formation
continue et nous sommes spécialisés dans
l'orientation des adultes et des jeunes
cet événement qui a lieu jeudi soir
quels sont les objectifs d'un tel
événement alors c'est donc en tant que
partenaire le dea bm est partenaire de
c'était des métiers là c'était des
métiers est un lieu ressources en termes
d'emploi de formation et d'orientation
et face à l'anxiété des parents qui
viennent à la cité des métiers tout au
long de l'année parce qu'il ya beaucoup
à la cité des métiers propose beaucoup
de choses en termes de conseil de
formation et d'information pour les pour
les jeunes voilà on a décidé
effectivement de faire une grande soirée
dédiée aux parents pour leur proposer de
d'appréhender au mieux l'orientation de
leur enfant en étant le moins stressés
possible l'orientation sans stress est
ce que c'est possible il ya forcément
des choix difficiles à faire pour qu'ils
vont décider du parcours du jeune on
peut aussi se tromper dans son
orientation est ce que c'est possible de
s'orienter sans prestation est anxiogène
donc on peut pas dire que et génère du
stress de toute façon mais en tout cas
de mieux connaître l'orientation donc on
présente vraiment avec différents
partenaires
voilà nous on est là en tant que coach
en orientation on a aussi une
psychologue qui sera là lors de cette de
cette soirée on a aussi une personne qui
va parler vraiment des grandes réformes
parcours superbe feinte des outils
parcours super de la réforme la actuelle
du baccalauréat donc en termes
d'information donc de toutes façons
c'est stressant on peut pas empêcher ce
stress mais en tout cas l'oriental
souhaite une vraie démarche et donc
d'expliquer cette démarche aux parents
de mieux leur faire comprendre ce qu'est
l'orientation c'est vraiment les aider à
mieux accompagner leurs enfants et à
moins projeté leurs peurs aussi parce
que finalement moi je me rends compte
dans ma pratique que les parents souvent
beaucoup plus stressé que les enfants
humaine voilà s'il est d'autant plus
importante car les parents c'est les
premiers relais finalement des enfants
les premiers conseillers on peut dire d
enfance aisée d'autant plus important
d'adresser cette soirée aux parents
voilà parce que les parents il a un vrai
rôle à prendre et un juste milieu voilà
ni trop ni pas assez
mais en tout cas ce qu'était ce qui est
intéressant c'est que paraît pour
discuter pas mal avec les parents les
parents se retiennent souvent en se
disant on ne veut pas projeter sur nos
enfants
voilà nous nous nos échecs nos parcours
nous nos souhaits mais en même temps moi
je me rends compte que le jeune il a
besoin d'avoir des propositions face de
lui pour avoir un muret pouvoir
argumenter se poser des questions voilà
le l'orientation interroge le désir du
jeune et il a besoin de se confronter
donc les parents il faut pas qu'ils
hésitent à voile a évoqué en tout cas où
proposer des pistes plusieurs choses au
programme de cette soirée vous animerez
vous une conférence sur le thème comment
aider vos enfants à s'orienter
justement il sera question de rendre
cette démarche positive le directement
c'est vraiment de d'expliquer la
démarche de lever aussi tout tout tout
ces points d'anxiété c'est une période
difficile aussi l'ado est adossé son
premier choix d'adulte
donc c'est d'expliquer un peu tous ces
mécanismes qu'est ce qui se met en place
qu'est ce qui peut venir freiner et
bloquer l'orientation et à partir du
moment où on connaît mieux ses freins de
pouvoir les lever en tout cas de bien
prendre conscience que c'est une
démarche à moyen terme c'est pas un coup
de baguette magique l'orientation c'est
une vraie démarche avec un processus
voilà qui va se mettre en place et des
étapes qui vont voilà qui vont se suivre
donc c'est ça que je que je propose
d'expliquer aux parents avec une vraie
volonté de leur donner des billes et
dévoila et des astuces
en tout cas il ressort de cette soirée
voilà soulagés les épaules tombe un peu
et on sent que ça leur ça leur fait du
bien on répondrait cette question
sûrement je dis mais comment les aider
justement leur leurs enfants sans sans
les freiner dans leur projet peut-être
qu'il peut qui peuvent sembler fou des
fois des projets des enfants certains
qui veulent faire voilà des des métiers
plus ou moins différents comment comment
les aider de les enlever
la première chose c'est d'écouter son
jeune ne pas tout de suite par
effectivement des idées qui peuvent nous
sembler farfelue mais vraiment de sonder
l'intention qui est derrière
l'énonciation je vais être médecin j'ai
il a 5 ans matt donc le parent très vite
va se dire un médecin mais qui pense
même pas mais non en fait c'est vraiment
les vocations cake et qu'est-ce que ça
c'est l'intention en fait le sens que ça
a
pourquoi le jeune dit je veux faire
médecine il ya un sens derrière
et donc c'est plus ça qu'il faut
investiguer que le fait d'avoir la bonne
pile le bon choix ou le mauvais choix en
fait c'est l'intention de l'énonciation
de choix du jeune qu'il faut brûler vie
telle écoute c'est vraiment la chose la
plus importante à la est tout tout
l'argumentaire derrière que le jeune
peut peut livrer qu'il livre
difficilement qu'il peut livrer
difficilement à ses parents plus
facilement à une personne extérieure un
tiers voilà pour donc ça fait partie
d'une des unes des pistes déjà voilà
mais ya pas mal de choses des choses qui
seront évoqués du coup jeudi soir petit
tacle à la cité des métiers je rappelle
que cet after work orientation sans
stress c'est ce jeudi à la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
le rendez vous est fixé de 18h à 21h et
on retrouve toutes les informations sur
le site internet de la cité des métiers
de saint quentin en yvelines merci à une
capitan merci beaucoup et en éducation
coach en orientation pardon aux et des
bd abm 78 merci à d'être passé en
plateau c'est un nom qui compte dans le
monde de la danse thierry malandain
étaient présents le week-end dernier à
saint quentin en yvelines avec le ballet
de biarritz et le chorégraphe est bien
connu sur le territoire saint quentinois
puisqu'il est le fils de l'actuel maire
de trappes guy malandain
il proposait deux de ses créations sur
la scène nationale du théâtre national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines mélanie
poker
[Musique]
deux partitions anciennes thierry
malandain propose écriture
chorégraphique nouvelle nocturne du fait
penser aux danses macabres moyenâgeuse
il choisit de travailler sur les lignes
ses danseurs évoluent sur un tapis de
mettre en espace contraint qui amuse le
créateur bon comme la les nocturnes de
chopin c'est des musiques connues donc
ça permet au public d'être à la fois au
niveau de l'oreille en terrain familier
et puis voir des images différentes
j'ai toujours aimé chopin ce qui se
passe que l'ordinaire de la compagnie cc
des pièces de commande souvent des
oeuvres d'une soirée et autres quand je
peux je m'attache à des musiques que
j'aime et chopin j'aime depuis toujours
et je n'avais jamais eu l'occasion de
faire quoi que ce soit le chorégraphe
français proposé à saint quentin en
yvelines deux créations dans un néo
classicisme qui le caractérise et qu'il
revendique au romantisme de chopin
bistrot répond de manière joyeuse
[Musique]
l'ambiance est joyeuse mais nous manque
en même temps là il y en à peine plus
spirituel même que la joie et aussi est
éphémère et yari moment il faut passer
de l'autre côté de la musique de vivaldi
elle appelle à la dynamique afin si ça
va mal et un peu plus virtuoses au
niveau des ensembles un retour dans une
agglomération que thierry malandain
connais bien en 1986 il fonde sa
compagnie à elancourt avant de partir
pour saint-etienne puis biarritz la
compagnie revient dans les yvelines en
juin prochain pour quatre
représentations à l'opéra royal de
versailles
après les fêtes prolonger les moments en
famille c'est l'ambition de
l'association plaisir oise pour la
promotion du théâtre et du spectacle
vivant vivant elle proposait le week-end
dernier un atelier un travail de
découverte du théâtre à vivre en binôme
patrick jacques de dixmude et mélanie
poker après les exercices de découverte
un peu de mise en pratique à plaisir
certain faisait ce week-end leurs
premiers pas sur scène
les participants sont tous présents en
binôme les parents accompagnent leurs
enfants ou inversement
j'aime bien parce que quand on fait du
théâtre en coller le livre de rencontrer
d'autres gens voire des moments ensemble
autre que manger regarder sa montre
faire les devoirs a toujours regardé sa
montre là j'ai vraiment apprécié le fait
d'être ensemble et de placer un mot
tous les deux c'est mon cadeau de noël
donc il m'a dit tiens je vais t'offrir
ça tu vas venir avec moi au théâtre moi
comme gens prêts à côté j'ai déjà fait
des exercices et du coup j'ai je
réexplique un petit peu j'avais envie de
le partager ça avec elle est là dessus
titouan mon petit garçon s'est greffée
avec mon mari
un atelier parent enfant imaginé par
l'association plaisir oise pour la
promotion du théâtre et du spectacle
vivant
le temps d'une journée les bases ont été
abordés travail sur le corps la voix ou
encore les émotions pour certains c'est
de découvrir la passion de l'autre de
mieux comprendre aussi du cool pourquoi
cette passion pourquoi ça peut être
aussi prenant l atelier est proposé pour
la deuxième année consécutive par
l'association plaisir oise un prochain
stage est prévu au mois de mars destiné
cette fois aux adultes et j'aime cette
lutte
on vous laisse et j'accueille aurélie
ronces bonsoir le 7 8 7 8 culture ce
soir sur tv 70 12 en est la
présentatrice au menu ce soir que
proposez vous alors on va parler d'un
festival le festival plein feux sur les
planches qui va se dérouler à maurepas à
partir du 18 janvier pendant trois
semaines quatre troupes de théâtre
amateurs vont présenter leur spectacle
ce sera l'espace albert camus il s'agit
de la cinquième édition pour les
amateurs de peinture et d'histoire et
bien nous irons musée à lambiner à
versailles jusqu'au 1er mars une
exposition vous propose de partir à la
découverte de 100 personnages
représentatifs de la cour de louis 15 et
2 louis saez et puis nous parlerons
musique avec le small bazar full band
c'est un groupe composé d'une trentaine
de musiciens qui se produira le 25
janvier prochain à voisins le bretonneux
l' orchestre va vous inviter un
véritable voyage en musique nous avons
pu suivre une de leurs répétitions et
donc c'est à découvrir dans les
prochaines minutes
merci aurélie le 7-8 culture dans
quelques instants sur tv 78 c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi une
nouvelle édition a retrouvé et dès
demain mercredi
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]